your hip consists of two main parts that
fit together like a ball and socket the
femoral head at the top of the leg and
the acetabulum in your pelvis
cartilage between the femoral head and
acetabulum provides cushioning between
the bones and allows for smooth movement
a total hip replacement is usually done
when severe damage from arthritis or
injury has made it difficult to perform
daily activities without severe pain or
restricted range of motion during the
procedure the femoral head and
acetabulum are replaced with artificial
components called prostheses an
artificial hip prosthesis consists of a
cup called the acetabular component and
a stem and ball called the femoral
component
before your procedure you will receive
intravenous fluids antibiotics and
medications to help you relax most
minimally invasive anterior total hip
replacements are done under spinal
anesthesia so you will be awake during
your operation but feel no pain a
catheter may be placed in your bladder
to drain your urine since fluid and
blood loss can be significant banked
blood will be prepared in case you
require a transfusion you may have the
opportunity to collect and store your
own blood in preparation for your
surgery
during a direct anterior total hip
replacement procedure you will lie on
your back on a specialized table
enabling your surgeon to perform this
minimally invasive operation your feet
will be placed in Boots attached to the
table allowing your surgeon to position
your legs as necessary to gain access to
your hip joint during your operation a
fluoroscopy machine may be used during
the procedure to help your surgeon
position your prosthesis more accurately
your surgeon will Begin by making a
three to six inch incision near your
groin this incision is significantly
smaller than those made during other
total hip replacement procedures
he or she will then push aside two
muscles to expose The Joint capsule no
muscles are split or detached during
this procedure
after incising the joint capsule your
surgeon will dislocate the femoral head
from the acetabulum he or she will
remove any damaged cartilage or bone in
the acetabulum reshape the acetabular
socket and secure the acetabular
prosthesis in place using special cement
or screws
turning next to the femur your surgeon
will remove the femoral head shape the
remaining femur to fit the prosthetic
stem and secure the femoral component
using cement or other techniques
once both components are firmly in place
your surgeon will slide the prosthetic
femoral head into its acetabular
counterpart
test the movement of your new hip joint
and may verify that it is properly
positioned with an x-ray
your surgeon will then close the joint
capsule and reposition your muscles he
or she may place a drain in your hip to
remove excess fluid and close the
incision with stitches or Staples
after your procedure you will be moved
to the post-surgical recovery area for
monitoring you will continue your IV
fluids and antibiotics for a short time
and will be given pain medications as
needed if a catheter was placed it will
be removed to prevent blood clots from
forming in your leg you will be given a
blood thinner asked to wear compression
stockings
and encouraged to begin walking as soon
as possible initially with a walker or
cane your physician may use a sequential
compression device on your legs or feet
to further decrease the possibility of
developing a blood clot called a deep
vein thrombosis or DVT in your leg veins
no hip precautions are necessary you may
sit Bend and cross your legs however you
want you will be released from the
hospital after you can walk up and down
stairs usually after two to four days
the anterior approach avoids cutting any
hip muscles which may result in
increased joint stability lower risk of
dislocation less pain and faster
recovery